minutes after submitting his nomination
papers to run for president
this is what police did to bobby wine's
car
his party officials streamed this video
live on social media
he was dragged out bundled into a police
van
and driven off
[Music]
just moments before the pop star turned
opposition politician
had completed the nomination process in
uganda's capital kampala
he wants to challenge president yoeri
masevani who's been in office for 34
years
we have not witnessed a peaceful
transfer of power
from one leader to another since our
country became
independent in 1962. like idiyamin
museveni declared himself president for
life in our country uganda the day
before
the 70 completed his nomination to run
again for president
the opposition complains that past
elections have been rigged
the electoral commission denies it this
time
campaign rallies are forbidden the
government says
because of the global pandemic corona
please
observe observe the guidelines
but secondly peace the one who wants to
bring you to to disturb
don't try because we shall deal with you
another presidential candidate who
represents the largest opposition party
in parliament
was arrested by police on his way to the
nomination
he was later dropped off at the venue by
police without his shoes
this is extremely annoying bobby wine
was later released
he's popular among young ugandans
especially in towns and cities
the polls are due to take place early
next year
uganda's past elections have brought
street protests and police crackdowns
this one looks to be no different
malcolm webb
al jazeera